BORDER CITY OF TIJUANA AND
MEXICO.
>> Lisa: THANK YOU, I
APPRECIATE IT.
JOINING ME NOW WITH REACTION,
AND CULTURE, CONSERVATIVE
COMMENTATOR AND AUTHOR OF
"RESISTANCE IS FUTILE.
ALSO, ALLEN ORR, IMMIGRATION AND
CIVIL RIGHTS ATTORNEY.
I WANT TO START WITH YOU.
WHAT RECOURSE DOES THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION HAVE IN DEALING
WITH THE MIGRANTS THAT ARE
ILLEGALLY CROSSING THE BORDER
WHILE TRYING TO SEEK ASYLUM?
>> WELL, I THINK MAY BE HAVING
FIREARMS WOULD BE HELPFUL.
THAT WAS HILARIOUS.
WHAT?
THEY ARE BRITISH COPS, THEY
DON'T HAVE GUNS?
DO THEIR TROOPS ON THEY HAVE
FIREARMS?
THIS IS A LITTLE MORE IMPORTANT
IN PROTECTING SOUTH KOREA, AS
IMPORTANT AS THAT IS.
IT'S OUR COUNTRY.
THERE ARE A LOT OF THINGS TRUMP
COULD DO IF HE HAS TO, IF HE'S
NOT GOING TO BUILD A WALL, WHICH
APPARENTLY HE ISN'T.
HE COULD GO A FEW YARDS INTO
MEXICO, HAVE AN EMERGENCY
MILITARY ACTION THERE.
BUT I DON'T THINK IT'S GOING TO
HELP WITH BILLY CLUBS.
[LAUGHS]
>> Lisa: ALLEN -- SO SECRETARY
CHRISTY NIELSEN SAID YESTERDAY
THAT THERE ARE 500
CRIMINAL -- IN THE MIX OF THE
MIGRANTS AS WELL AS GANG
MEMBERS.
I WANT TO PLAY SOME SOUND FOR
YOU, FORMER I.C.E. DIRECTOR TOM
HOMAN AND GET YOUR THOUGHTS ON
IT.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> I WAS CALLED A FEAR
MONGERRER.
FORTUNATELY I WAS RIGHT.
WE WILL TALK ABOUT MORE CARAVANS
ENTERING ILLEGALLY, PUTTING
THEIR HANDS IN CRIMINAL
ORGANIZATIONS, BANKROLLING DRUG
CARTELS WHO CONTROL THE CORRIDOR
WAS HEADING TO THE BORDER.
THESE PEOPLE ARE PUT AT RISK.
WOMEN WILL BE RAPED, PEOPLE WILL
DIE, CHILDREN ALL DROWN, PEOPLE
WILL BE MISUSED, AS WE HAVE SEEN
OVER AND OVER, HOW MANY PEOPLE
HAVE DIED AT THE HEADS OF THESE
CRIMINALS.
>> Lisa: ALLEN, TO MR. TOM
HOMAN'S BOARD, AS WELL AS WITH
SECRETARY NIELSEN LAID OUT,
AREN'T THEY ARE REAL NATIONAL
SECURITY CONCERNS AND DEFENSE
CONCERNS AT THIS ON THE BORDER
RIGHT NOW?
>> I DON'T THINK THERE ARE ANY
MORE CONCERNS THAN ANY OTHER
BORDER.
EVERY DAY, HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF INDIVIDUALS OF WHITE EDGE OF
THIS COUNTRY.
SPECIFICALLY AT THE TIJUANA
PORT, AT LEAST 100,000
INDIVIDUALS APPLY EVERY DAY.
AN EXTRA 2,004,000 UNITED STATES
AN EXTRA 2,004,000 UNITED STATEA
AN EXTRA 2,004,000 UNITED STATEE
AN EXTRA 2,004,000 UNITED STATEL
AN EXTRA 2,004,000 UNITED STATEB
AN EXTRA 2,004,000 UNITED STATEE
AN EXTRA 2,004,000 UNITED STATEF
AN EXTRA 2,004,000 UNITED STATER
ENTRY, SHOULD NOT BE A PROBLEM
FOR THE UNITED STATES.
THEREFORE, THIS WHOLE THING IS
BASICALLY THEATER, POLITICAL
THEATER --
>> Lisa: HOW SO?
>> THE CARAVAN HAS BEEN COMING
FOR YEARS.
ANN HAS HAD THAT.
THIS IS THE FIRST TIME I HAVE
DEPLOYED ACTUALLY -- THE
NATIONAL GUARD AND THE TROOPS OF
THE BORDER, --
>> Lisa: NOT THE FIRST
PRESIDENT TO SEND TROOPS TO THE
BORDER.
PRESIDENT OBAMA DID THAT,
PRESIDENT GEORGE W. BUSH,
PRESIDENT H.W. BUSH, CERTAINLY
NOT THE FIRST PRESIDENT TO DO
THAT.
>> NOT TO SEND TO THE BORDER AT
THIS LEVEL AND THIS NUMBER AND
OF THIS MAGNITUDE TO ADDRESS
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE COMING HERE
AND WHICH I DON'T EVEN CALL THEM
A CARAVAN, I CALLED THEM
SURVIVORS BECAUSE THEY ARE
FLEEING FOR THEIR LIVES.
TO ME PEOPLE WHO ARE FLEEING FOR
THEIR LIVES WITH GUNS INSTEAD
WELCOMING THEM AND USING THE
AMERICAN LAWS THAT WE'VE AGREED
ON FROM CONGRESS TO LET THEM TO
APPLY FOR ASYLUM, THAT IS NOT
VERY AMERICAN.
>> Lisa: IS NOT JUST
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND REPUBLICANS
WHO HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT IS GOING
ON.
WE HAVE THE TIJUANA MAYOR
WEARING A HAT SAYING, "MAKE
TIJUANA MADE DON'T MIGRATE
AGAIN, MEXICAN PROTESTERS SAYING
THIS IS OUR COUNTRY
, WHAT YOU MAKE OF WHAT ALLEN
JUST SAID?
>> THAT IS THE PROOF POSITIVE
THAT THEY ARE NOT FLEEING FOR
THEIR LIVES, WHICH IS WHY, FOR
ASYLUM, YOU EITHER HAVE TO APPLY
IN YOUR HOME COUNTRY OR YOU
APPLY IN THE FIRST COUNTRY YOU
COME TO.
ALL THE MEXICAN PROTESTERS -- BY
THE WAY, I GUESS IT'S FUN
NEEDLING THE MEXICANS FOR BEING
HYPOCRITES ON ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION, BUT I REALLY CARE
WHAT MEXICO'S POLICY IS.
THIS IS OUR COUNTRY.
OUR POLICY SHOULD BE WHAT
DONALD TRUMP RAN ON.
WE ARE TRYING TO RUN THE COUNTRY
HERE.
IT ISN'T AN INTERNATIONAL LOUNGE
AT JFK.
YOU HAVE TO APPLY EITHER IN THE
COUNTRY YOU ARE IN OR THE FIRST
COUNTRY YOU COME TO BRIGHTS
BECAUSE THAT IS FACTUALLY NOT
CORRECT.
PLEASE STOP SAYING THAT.
>> Lisa: ALLEN, WHY AREN'T
THESE MIGRANTS DOING AT THE
RIGHT WAY?
WHY AREN'T THEY GOING TO PARTS
OF AUTHORITY?
WHY DO YOU SEE SOME OF THEM
BREAKING THE LAW AND ILLEGALLY
CROSSING THE BORDER IF THEY
TRULY HAVE A CREDIBLE FEAR
THRESHOLD THAT IS BEING MET, WHY
DON'T THEY DO WITH THE RIGHT
WAY?
>> LET'S CORRECT THE RECORD.
YOU CAN'T APPLY FOR ASYLUM IN
YOUR HOME COUNTRY.
IT DOES NOT WORK THAT WAY.
THERE IS A RULE THAT YOU CAN
APPLY TO THEIR FIRST COUNTRY,
WHICH WE MEXICO --
>> Lisa: THEY ARE ILLEGALLY
CROSSING THE BORDER.
>> IN MEXICO, OVER THE COURSE OF
THE LAST COUPLE OF THE MONTH,
THEY HAVE ACCEPTED MORE
IMMIGRANTS THAN THE LAST COUPLE
OF MONTHS.
MORE THAN THE UNITED STATES HAS.
SO ALL THOSE THINGS COMBINED,
PEOPLE FLEEING FOR THEIR LIVES,
COMING THOUSANDS OF MILES, THEY
DON'T OVER THE PORT OF ENTRY IS.
IF YOU'VE NEVER BEEN TO A CITY
BEFORE, YOU DON'T KNOW WHERE THE
PORT IS.
PRAYED CONTINUALLY, COME
OF THIS ADMINISTRATION HAS MADE
IT HARD FOR INDIVIDUALS WHO DO
APPEAR AT THE PORT.
AS YOU'VE SEEN ON TUESDAY, THE
PRESIDENT CLOSED DOWN THE PORT
FOR NO REASON OTHER THAN FEAR
AND THEN ONLY ALLOWING A COUPLE
FAMILIES AT A TIME.
THEREFORE, THIS CONCEPT OF THEM
CROSSING THE BORDER ILLEGALLY OR
THEM BEING ILLEGAL OR THEM BEING
ILLEGAL ALIENS WHERE THEY ARE
NOT EVEN IN A COUNTRY REALLY,
WHAT WE STOP THE LAW ALLOWS, THE
CONSTITUTION ALLOWS, THROUGH THE
ADMINISTRATION, IT DOES NOT
MATTER HOW THEY ENTER THE
COUNTRY, BETWEEN COURTS, WHICH
WE HEARD FROM THE NINTH CIRCUIT,
THEY ARE ALLOWED TO APPLY FOR
ASYLUM.
IF WE WANT TO CHANGE THAT, WE
SHOULD CHANGE CONGRESS.
>> Lisa: THE LAWS ARE BEING
EXPLOITED, WE KNOW THAT IS A
FACT.
8% OF THESE INDIVIDUALS PASSING
THEIR INITIAL THRESHOLD WITH
IMMIGRATION OFFICIALS AND THEN
ONLY 20% ARE ACTUALLY GRANTED
ASYLUM AND IMMIGRATION COURT.
THAT IS ALSO A FACT.
I WANT TO GET YOUR TAKE, ANN, ON
WHAT CHIEF JUSTICE ROBERTS
RECENTLY SAID, CRITICIZING
PRESIDENT TRUMP, GOING AFTER THE
NINTH CIRCUIT, SAYING WE DO NOT
HAVE OBAMA JUDGES ARE TRUMPED
JUDGES, BUSH JUDGES OR CLINTON J
JUDGES, BUSH JUDGES OR CLINTON D
JUDGES, BUSH JUDGES OR CLINTON E
JUDGES, BUSH JUDGES OR CLINTON .
WE HAVE EXTRAORDINARY GROUP OF
DEDICATED JUDGES.
YOUR THOUGHTS ON THAT?
>> I WARNED THE COUNTRY ABOUT
JUSTICE ROBERTS.
I THOUGHT HE WAS A MISTAKE.
THE ONE THING I WILL DEFINITELY
GIVE PRESIDENT TRUMP CREDIT FOR,
APPOINTING JUSTICES LIKE
KAVANAUGH AND NOT HARRIET MIERS
AND JUSTICE ROBERTS.
I DON'T KNOW WHY -- I HAVE A LOT
OF COMPLAINTS WITH TRUMP.
I'M GLAD HE'S APPOINTING JUDGES
THAT ARE ENFORCING THE LAW AND
YES, THE LAW IS YOU SEEK ASYLUM
IN THE FIRST COUNTRY YOU GET TO.
YOU ARE BY DEFINITION NOT
FLEEING FOR YOUR LIFE WHEN YOU
ARE TREKKING THROUGH THOUSANDS
OF MILES OF OTHER COUNTRIES, AND
OH, WELL, WELFARE ISN'T GOOD
ENOUGH HERE IN MEXICO, I THINK
I'LL KEEP GOING.
THE REASON WE KEEP GOING TO THE
U.S. OF THE REASON IT MAKES A
DIFFERENCE WHERE WE SET UP THE
TROOPS, THEY SHOULD BE, AS I
SAID, A FEW YARDS INTO MEXICO,
ONCE A NONMEXICAN STEPS ON U.S.
SOIL, WE CAN'T TURN THEM AWAY.
THE IDEA WAS TO STOP HUMAN
SMUGGLING, WHEN IN FACT IT'S
DONE EXACTLY THE OPPOSITE.
IT'S CREATING HUMAN SMUGGLING.
MEXICANS, WE CAN TURN AWAY AT
THE BORDER.
IF WE CATCH THEM.
THAT IS WHY WE WANTED A WALL.
ANYONE WHO IS A NONMEXICAN, WHO
JUST WALKS THROUGH THIS ENORMOUS
COUNTRY, NOT FLEEING FOR THEIR
LIVES, LOOKING FOR BETTER
WELFARE, ONCE THEY STEP ON U.S.
SOIL, WE CAN'T JUST SEND THEM
HOME, WE HAVE TO GIVE THEM
HEARINGS.